[Musik]
sie tourte ist es ein traum für menschen
die dir zwar und später nach ankara
geflogen
[Musik]
der zoll ist so populär wie nie die
zwölfte treffer der schweiz zur eu
gehören zu den beliebtesten ausflugsziel
mit millionen von besuchern
[Musik]
ich bin eigentlich kein fan im garten
die spender merkwürdig
[Musik]
sie sind wir alles geordnet
expertensuche gemein sondern die hand
ihres territorium die tränen sind uns
gleich gar nicht eingesetzt und la mica
überraschen
[Musik]
unsere frage stellen die psyche für die
die ja auch faszinieren uns begeistern
[Musik]
wie die schweiz entstanden ist sieht
android und axel höpner braucht das wort
der firma finder
[Musik]
bucher bett im basler zoo ja die heißt
das neugeborene panzernashorn es
menschlich
der tierpfleger roland schweizer wird
ihnen also ein messer versichert sie das
ist auch gut entwickelt
neben die chalets masse publikum ein
bisschen nervös ob sie laut das
eigentlich zu max burger ist doch wahr
und wie schnell ich ja was mir sei das
ist frei geworden ist so zwischen 50 und
80 kilo schwer sind und das ist ja dann
scheuer uninteressant zu
ja aber es hat reichen tag zwei kilo zu
das ist ideal
also muss ich hoffe wir haben ja aber
die wirklich stehen ja es muss ein
signal sondern es müssen außerdem bliebe
und mehr waren so wenige mögliche
einflussnahme zugleich es muss sichtbar
ja aber es konnten aber damals einfach
mit der schaufel transfer
der bauchumfang stimmt im jahr prächtig
was nach der ankunft ist es besonders
schön ist wenn man dann sagt sie das sei
eine milliarde ist dreißigste
panzernashorn bottrop sucht vor dem tier
ist für bass eine einmalige
erfolgsgeschichte
[Musik]
nach vorne hätte 50er jahre das wilde
panzernashorn bild indien für basel zog
fangen
[Musik]
nach einer lange es trifft verwirrt im
zoo motivation hessen chiplead woche
gibt es große schlagzeilen
das panzernashorn weibchen im basler zoo
hat ein kind zur welt gebracht
das gar nicht ahnt welche sensation ist
bedeutet es ist das erste in
gefangenschaft geborene panda lhasa und
der welt die mutter findet es schön und
wer wagte es die kindliche anmut des
neugeborenen zu bezweifeln dass
unachtsame mit beschädige zucht von
panzern us-teams basel zieht begehrt
[Musik]
der heutige direktor olivier baku ist
stolz sinne nashorn ist besitzt auch
verrückt
so wird der erkrankung dass ich nie
routine ich freue mich riesig dass
wiederum stand ruhig dass ich jedes mal
das ergebnis ob es seit jeher malik dir
das gut das ist ganz schön stil auch
anfang an ist von der jetzt dass sie
aber dass ich habe da kontrast los
geht's mit großer große mit wachs ihre
großer farbig koordiniert bastelt weiter
sucht von einer stark bedrohte tier das
ist internationale zuchtbuch
panzernashörner das hätte so riesig ins
170 und warum hätten wir das nicht
gemacht damals dass es nicht dass auch
weitergab
wenn andere institution errichtet hat
dass man das unkoordinierte macher und
den händen von der bravo maalouf
liebsten tut wofür mit panzernashörner
rufen weil es die menschen bolt und wo
werden sie transferiert und wo steht die
frage nach raúl war mit wellen so beck
weiter so wird züchtet wird für die
sehnsucht der 30 stellen aber das stimmt
folge aus dem windpark lich für
mitte-links institution dass man das
richtige mann mit dem richtigen blick
dazu geht dass es keine zucht junge aber
letztens außer eigentlich vor dem
ursprünglichen budget teams geld würde
das heißen
die senators robert irgendwie verdammt
panzer von den tatsachen so gott sei
dank jetzt auch ein paar andere
institutionen wurden bald auf züchtet an
aber das basler blutig sehr gut
verdrahtet und auch unser aktueller
zuchtbulle hätten günstige tarife bass
wird nur die sintflut obwohl auch in san
diego stellte schon basel vorherigen und
jetzt sein
[Musik]
panzernashorn cs wichtiges kapitel lange
geschichte vom basler tor
[Musik]
vor 150 jahren gründer vom zoologischen
gartens basel angst dass sich
bevölkerung genau dies nach von natur
und fanny start etwas betreuten kunden
und darum mit dem zuletzt natur bieten
wir noch bringen
im juli auf 240 sowie der zolli minute
barcelona die heimische tier zeigt
[Musik]
logitech sollte der zu holen freunde hat
mit den besuchern
[Musik]
zu tierhaut ich hätte nach der novelle
gedanken gemacht traffic krebs würde
verrät ihr bezwungen
hinter gitter
[Musik]
im zoo gezückt noch spuren aus der
ersten liga del vom land das braucht's
gebäude zeigt dass der zorn auf die
großzügige unterstützung für ihre basel
familie hätten
[Musik]
herbert 90 mit dem älteste gebäude vom 2
basis für die titel
also dass der mensch sich da im zentrum
befindet wird und dass der lage die
reihe um die menschen gebaut worden sind
warum hätten sollte markt im herzen so
gemacht weil man sich damals prof
jahrhundert waren die das ist so eine
clique haid gesichtsstraffung sonnig und
menschen im zoo und mancher an da darum
gefüllt und han trainer der beobachter
und zwar jede box jetzt oft bei dir gar
und es hat ganz verschiedene gab bis zu
98 er hätte mit deutschland ins rennen
als einzelnen bürger nur leider völlig
völlig anders wer heute weil man
natürlich die reichhaltigkeit vom
aktuellen zeige wie verschieden die dir
sind und hüte guides darum dass man die
gruppen erhalten durch das motiv züchtet
und das man soetwas verhaltensrepertoire
von einer tropennacht
[Musik]
schon vor 100 jahren hat man sich
gedanken gemacht zu zur gestaltung
[Musik]
zwölf jahre nach dem antilope hus ist
sehr loyal entstanden mit der ferse
später ein stück aber abzeichnet und
nach holz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in die stadt wo derzeit starke dehnung
[Musik]
kulisse war verblüffend acht wirkt wir
ihm eine moderne freizeitpark und so
wird die historische lok genutzt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für möglichst viel zu locker hat mit
frühere geschichte vom zoo aber nicht
mehr gesetzt
die bosenberg basel staatsarchiv es geht
da unterlagen zur düsteren kapitel von
basel zu
vor gut zwei jahren so siehts ganz
archive stadt übergab und es so
öffentlich zugänglich gemacht
assist josi dokumentation vorkasse zog
sich mit briefen techniker plan bildet
und filme
und was ist da aus so archiv das ist
natürlich laden in frieden jetzt einen
tag service klar man hat ja das ist
riesig
und da taucht im fotoalbum vom erster
browser direkt schier unglaublichen auf
das mal ruft
[Musik]
dazu hält während meinem york/münchen
uns gestellt
[Musik]
präsentiert wie dir in dazu auf distanz
zum publikum
[Musik]
eine 20 sogenannte volcker show heads im
zoo von 1890 bis 1935 gab die erfolgs
europa sind ganz europa unterwegs
[Musik]
besucher sowie tarot für die würde
mancher zu bestaunen
[Musik]
das sind aussichten zu deiner völker
schraube und zwar aus sicht rote karten
zur an sich das umland schickt oder sind
wenn man die völker schaut auch gut aus
oder man einfach eine implosion der
zeitung hatte die schau auf die
zurückgegangen ist möchte die dicken
zeigen
darum müssen wir von unterlassungs
ebenso gebaut und zusammenstehen und
arbeitsstelle zu und lief ins jahr
beschriftet ist
[Musik]
2007 brachte sich so oft zitiert
geliefert hat ist bekannt dass sich hand
in hand kommen
[Musik]
was fällt euch noch in tiergarten soll
ich liefern
deutschland hätte sich nicht sein dass
auf so was hat denn gemacht was mir
viele andere zoos und städte gemacht hat
freunde fortführt für couch verdienen
[Musik]
der historiker balthasar stellen ist der
es über das umfangreiche material von
basso zu dem thema wissenschaftlich
untersucht hat wie wichtig sie die
fotoshow für den 6 die völker scheiben
sind noch große publikumsmagnet ist das
gerät mit reza open air konzert zum teil
gar drei oder zwei wochen bis 50 30 lyko
alias interesse von exotik es ist die
ganze inszenierung von einer von einer
chance ist eine mischung zwischen
magisches wie wissenschafts anspruch und
zugleich ein spektrum das heißt wildheit
fanatismus gestellte menschen ins
zentrum gestellt
die fremde werte aus damaliger sicht
nimmt ihr werdet dem münch
vor 1900 sind zum beispiel darauf saß
als als halb nackt im ton aber auch das
ist möglich dass zum teil mit gesetzen
der rasse bricht fast ein bisserl
sexuell die redaktion hat keine
bestrafung für die völker schreiben dass
dinge die nach den nachmittagen intensiv
auseinandergesetzt hat also die ente
internet ziehen und die anträge dazu die
andere war vor seiner nacht begossen und
in die restaurativen bestätigte es ist
ganz klar uns druck auf einmal macht
gefallen zwischen europa und dann land
auch die mitschnitte menschen sind
normal ist
so wie diese können ihre kinder
freiwillig gegen bezahlung haben sie an
deiner und eine anteilige ob sich sehr
wenig bekannt über ihre perspektiv und
das ist eine wahrscheinlich von der
große sagen wir wissen acker in der
reform dass wir sehr wenig weiß wird die
zahl betonen dass gestellt worden sind
1905 gastieren not marokkaner die
freundin helga paris verloren ging
wenige jüdische ökologie stilett die
völker in der schweiz
[Musik]
so zügig
es ist morgen im sack sie die b
unterwegs mit dem früheren tierpfleger
fritz busch
[Musik]
obwohl längst pensioniert ich hätte der
schlüssel zum tor verpasste
[Musik]
und so humorlos von der molke stimmig
otto bryde kleine besucher hätten sich
acht magisch
[Musik]
jack und schönemoor ich gut schlafen
friedburg gekentert sowie 240 org vorne
quer später wird die pflege und der
betriebsleiter des islam und verletzung
[Musik]
dort möchte schnappe so gut gemeinte
städtischen heutigen modernen wirklich
vorne schaut man sich die von roll ist
das einfach und sie stellen auch einen
ort und wasserwandern fest sich projekt
ich ich gehe deutsch-griechen musste
stand st
ja das sind darüber wohnen
mit in friedburg spürte ich lebe rum der
zur so fasziniert und jahr millionen
besucher anlockt
[Musik]
das ist der stoff wurde pfarrer da
schlafen sie ja durch wunderschöner die
härte wenn wir da auch gesehen dass
patrick und heute ist dass europa mit
gegen 20 uhr um heike bergt ich finde
die jeden fall zu fertigen noch nicht an
das schon so früh zeichnete die
community der angespülte die
gefolgschaft
die lappen die wissen ich glaube es ist
so die als friedens und der glücklichste
er wieder fester beziehung zwischen wann
kann die dritte hätte hätte ich nicht
mal wieder schaffe
[Musik]
schicht vom zoo zürich sozial 1929
zurück solche tiere zum 50 jahr nach der
partie
[Musik]
so hat immer konkurs einfach ein
familien
[Musik]
so ganz sicher sie sich gründer nick sie
dass ihre so wird funktionieren
direkter ist der zoologe und stellt sie
sich jahrelang mit aller kraft wird
schafik vor dem ziel setzt
seine jüngste tochter regula am 16
was er aber ausdrücklich verzichtet
[Musik]
für ihn ist das wirtschaftliche
kulturelle faktoren für ihre stadt er zu
und erkundete slow mit nötig sei
das ist spannend so gezwungen zur
mitarbeit unter sich zu ziehen stadt
zürich hat in einer phase von expansion
sie steht hat der kunde nicht so moore
sind platz h aber für viele ist das
nicht sexy es hat absolut kein politiker
seiten des tisches hobby vorteile
nothelle dass er selber finanzieren und
die andere große aufgabe für ihn ist sie
also man hat umso besser erstmal was
gibt es überhaupt für die betroffenen
sondern man hat die vor allem ihren
dreht so hat man die bezogen
aber man hat eine solo gab es für dirk
überhaupt dollar
die hätte 27 ukrainisches klage die
richtige tierbesitzer selbst
transportieren und als klimatisieren
jetzt muss richtig futter und luca dass
sie überleben
[Musik]
600 zeuge tier und falco hat mediola
gebracht
[Musik]
sieht so hätte die werk traunsteiner
mitgliederschaft vertrieben
erich wirklich begeistert von der
schönheit von tier und für süße riegel
und hunde sondern die halter sexy der
spruch ist gesprungen so ist fulminant
gestartet
[Musik]
im ersten monat 150 besucher ruft dazu
die bank
[Musik]
peter hat sich niemand gestört gründete
sich durchaus gedanken gemacht zu tätig
aber der direktorenstelle hat ihr
möglichst gut sichtbar machen und später
herkömmlichen lager blieb als kompromiss
jetzt bitte geh und startlinie außerdem
k
[Musik]
so gut der zoo zürich startet ist so
hettich implantat nachbar jahr
es ist im kredit blieb es auch
etablieren wirtschaftskrise hätten herr
prof
und jackie ist derzeit beiträge sprache
die jungs oft unüberwindbare
schwierigkeiten gestellt von tierpfleger
am ersten tag von biomasse kilogramm
ihn zog sie ihr die frau gesprungen
zuvor treten jene haag land die
tierpfleger wo bliebe sie hätten aber
schlecht gestartet die nahrung der seine
schützlinge auf dem zoogelände so weit
wie möglich selbst anzupassen und auf
diese weise mithelfen den tod erhalten
fleisch ist knapp ziehen
der tierbestand müsse reduzieren und die
team um head messe.de grad aus furth im
traffic landet
[Applaus]
nummer der unterstützung von zoo
besucher noch suchen bevor der urlaub
mitgebracht hätten überhaupt überleben
[Musik]
die sachen futter und der kontrast zu
würzen nicht größer sie mich morgen
aufhören
[Musik]
und daher meisten sich alles erste
qualität des gegners der verein gewissen
standard ist aber sonst ist das alles
tipptopp sowie nord und das muss erste
kursnet aber für die breeze wo mir
anfangen so recht autorität und es ist
natürlich auch für für urs ringger wenn
du nichts gegen eine stunde mussten
das wird schnell das sind so genannten
us-kommission gemüse wofür fordert ja ja
die gibt es teilige jungen geschlagen
ein studium ja also ich sag jetzt los
klar und trocken
die ressourcen
[Musik]
ihr beitrag wird klar ist wird im zoo
nicht nur nahrung sondern oder tier
beschäftigen wird orden orte verteilt
[Musik]
honig
kämpferischer sehr einfach geschaut und
gebärende statiker vor unterirdischen
sich in mehreren funktionen so fertig
pastor computer gespräch aber gut dass
ich schon gebaut und muss auch so sein
[Musik]
die ganztags nichts dir ja der punkt
kommt an
ich glaube ja ja so ein kabbalah voller
und dabei erschlagen
[Musik]
zieht ihr budget dunkel im körper als
gaudi wird besucher
[Musik]
zeitnah wird seit jahren vom spektakel
nicht nur bei den opfern
viel heißt wie münchen riesenattraktion
fürs publikum hört ist so ein zirkus im
zoo und dankbar
solche tischmanieren bilden nicht nur
einen spaß für die besucher des zoos sie
geben auch den wärter gelegenheit seine
autorität oder wie der fachausdruck der
biologen lautet seine soziale
überlegenheit den schimpansen täglich in
erinnerung zu rufen
für menschlich zitiert typisch für die
damalige zeit
das ist auf der beckumer als hätte
spezielle geschichte
es ist erst gorilla überhaupt wo immer
europäische software groß kuh ist im zoo
basel im jahr 1959 gelungen
zusammen mit seiner frau der zoodirektor
anschlagen das auf abb höchstpersönlich
verhandelt zucker wenn man einen fünf
monate alten gorilla kinn zu essen gibt
muss man auf die gleiche geduldsprobe
gefasst sein wie bei einem menschenkind
der geduldige papa ist doktorand der
direktor des basler zudem das gorilla
mädchen goma mit händen und füßen
begreiflich macht dass es genug hat
herrn und frau doktor langs richtige
kinder sind schon erwachsen aber das
laufgitter aus früheren zeiten ist noch
gut zu gebrauchen
thoma benimmt sich durchaus wie ein
menschenkind in ein paar jahren wird
dieses kleine hilfebedürftige geschöpft
ein mächtiges 250 kilo schweres gorilla
weibchen sein und zog sich go modus
ermittelt wieder alte dame nova woche
hat sie in basel zur besuch von demba ba
vor 350 jahren vom damaligen zoodirektor
anschluss an ihre nummern oder begegnen
aber sie könnten sofort setzt sich im
ganzen roma ich für den juni ist lang
wie eine tochter der sich lieber sind
halb so lustig können wir wie sieht die
denn auf die dvd behält koma wo sieht
auch jungen aufgebraucht hat daheim
ihrer tag zurücklegt und sehe dass das
dass das junge nicht hat mich hund und
johannes zeit hat aus kitas geht der
handaufzucht und am anderen morgen ist
das junge ziemlich macht sie und hätten
verstehe und da habe ich sag jetzt muss
er warten also stirbt
roadshow print komatsu rookie crowe
hetzt sehr schmerzhaft denn wie die
gruppe ist über die jahre hat coma aber
ihre position gefunden
der jüngst basel zoodirektor olivier
pagan ich mit dem vorgänger anschlag
befreundet und kränze geschichte vor dem
komma genau möglich was grundsätzlich
ich danke dass damals die
pionierleistung
mal pionierleistung ist und tut was dass
die menschen auch verwenden immer
möglich bieten älteren und wachse die
welt er hat sehr viel gelernt damals
vorhaben wird der herr lang mit oma und
man festgestellt dass das rentiere vom
gorilla den sie in ihrer gruppe eine
schwierige sache ist und darum durch
lichte buslinie warte mit wagner von den
älteren dame aus der falsche ist ab
damals gestorben wir herzlich willkommen
und die andere menschenaffen sehr
richtiges loch oben der oliver becker
zeigt mir die neueste attraktion von
gaza zu
regional art of greece millionen franken
verbaut worden
im grundkurs klöckner der spielplatz für
die cleveren tiere
[Musik]
auch für des angebots ab überhaupt wert
ist ungewiss
[Musik]
also das ist natürlich dass wir jetzt
noch nicht weiß vielleicht römer sie
auch nicht aus am ersten tag mehr möchte
[Musik]
neueste technik ganz fertig der
eröffnungstag weiter - mit landgang
[Musik]
die schöne neue welt mit großzügige
kirche und ihr gleichzeitig war die
obama nicht
der heutige begründet foto tiergarten
biologie zur direkten spaß und ab 1952
mit ihm jetzt aber um wissenschaftlich
führte zur angefangen als die
mittelpunkt gestellt der zimmer
bedürfnis genau erforschen
der heutige breite publikum welcher uns
ganz im heutigen sinn nicht nur mit ihr
zeige sondern über sie und ihre ladung
vermittler mit der die zum beispiel
hätte zoodirektor henning ob es neue
sieg für infotainment und jetzt noch ein
chamäleon zeiten
es ist aber kein gewöhnliches chamäleon
sondern es haben sich da achtung achtung
das macht sich schon schießt fertig das
macht sich bereit und filter nach der
schlachtung auf der küchenschabe die
zunge kommt
der händler hat früher oft moritz und
publikum setzt der fritz pucher romans
jahr mit dem handy geschaut hat weiß das
aus eigener erfahrung
fritz buchen hat denn verrückte idee
kaum zu denken hätten verwirklichen
mit dem solo elvira ist tierpfleger
bucher der 50er jahre trainer später
stricker am krankenbett
die ausflug mit dem lama eine stadt
bekannt gemacht
[Musik]
richard dankte erfreut waren zum abitur
verzeichnet ganz anders und vor allem
oft wir noch zieht und so rund 90.000
der wasserrettung vorgeschlagen hat
meinen charakter und das soll gesprungen
dann haben wir das gemacht und
klassische kränze großer hit sie wohl
aller tätig ist und was nie abgesagt
überhaupt aber durchaus eine frontale
[Musik]
der zorn darüber dass sand zur grünen
beliebter park entwickelt
aber dir sich auf dem weitläufigen
klandt nur in das ist kein zufall
dazu profitiert mehr rückzug der
positive musik für der andere mehr platz
zu machen
im browser zum beispiel hetzerischer und
das war der ständer tier und ihr
bedürfnis steuern mittelpunkt vom zoo
[Musik]
direktor alex rübel führt dazu sieht
neben den 20 jahren wird es im zoo das
naturschutzzentrum machen
[Musik]
sie sind die folge ja ja ja
ursula hauer mit ihrer ist es im alex
rübel gelungen selber es dank mord
setzen
[Musik]
hier bewegt sich das publikum im la paz
rom vor der tür
83 das ist neu station konzept
firma denn zum stützt operator sprungs
gebiert würdet ihr tempo der masoala auf
madagaskar
[Musik]
diana geschäfts schon vor jahren würde
ich immer nur so
also da ihnen sind die die hier
eigentlich nicht gesperrt hamburg agrar
der mensch lauftraining die tierwelt
idee wald wo man outfits limes wirke
also hirsch einig wird im mittelpunkt
stehe und sich lappen im mittelpunkt und
knapp 1000 autos wobei und zur moderne
zu unterscheiden alter darf man einfach
grüne ich mir da nicht mehr da hat es
dir noch ein anderes sie werfen
silbertablett und dort linie hätten sehr
wohl die ihre musik es ist in ihrem in
ihrem garten machen dass diese bilden
ist auch die details sicherheitszonen
große fortschritte / zuschauer
anspruchsvoller haben herausforderer
geschäften durch husten haben wohl
letztlich häuser bester bildet als ein
einfacher staatssteuer zwei stunden zu
ihm ihr auszug suchen
für diese tierliebe und ist wie
informieren und bildern ziemlich viel
verlangt aber viel volk von masoala
halle geht am alex rübel 8
[Musik]
voraus so in fred 17 moore starb
offenbar lisa projekt perfekte kulisse
und nötige geld 250 millionen franken
die masoala halle kostet keine jux
projekt im ursprungsland vor der tür
sowohl sony als auch auf moderne zu
definiert was hierbei wird sogar für die
regionen wo die herkommen
der natürliche lebensraum vor ort so
duncan zuletzt weiter
[Musik]
pantanal heißt zum beispiel die polizei
ruft problematik von illegaler tierfarm
aufmerksam machen
der bildungsauftrag motto hier hörte
[Musik]
biertisch künstler im original
südamerikanische naturschutzgebiet nach
einem kunden
[Musik]
auf der insel aber dort bottroper
flieger glück und dort fahrenden flotte
der busy
[Musik]
schritt
harziger und lustige momente
zu deiner tier das publikum aber nur
stumme wieso begleitet da fliegt etwa
aus hollingstedt gang
[Musik]
herr über liebe da ihnen erklärt vor
zukunft zeigt jetzt die zusage für das
buch zuzüglich überhaupt es egal hier
wird der schöne illusion quad aber die
die sich später zu so sagt es die
genauso wenn also die asiin er freier
wildnis
das ist ein fehlschluss wenn man da das
wissenschaftlich hallo ergibt aber ich
bin der festen überzeugung dass bei mir
alles retiro sowieso überhaupt verdrängt
oder sage cattolica rustemi wie man ktm
dann verlieren wir unsere kontakt zur
natur und dann behandeln wir nachher
tierwelt und natur nun auch wenn rein
ist auch und das ist ja genau das was
eigentlich gesellschafter der andere 17
punkte die haupt das müsst ihr es stimmt
und das kann man nur wenn man sie
äußeren umwelt umwelt ihnen paul transit
geäußert und ähnlich also wie sichere
rübel der tag wo die zonen gibt darunter
nicht also den ersten zwei generationen
wage ich zu behaupten wird sind so oder
so ähnliche institution sichern und für
die nächste generation wird gesorgt
so ziert platz für widrige im großen
stil der elefantenpark so 2014 aufgaben
aber begrenzt
ständig neu die weitläufige und
artgerecht die außenanlage wird wünschen
office parat für technik das ist das 27
september 2012
gespannt ob die auch immer wir müssen
nicht lange warten
[Musik]
die erste war und ist immer sehr wohl
schon so viel gesehen und erlebt sagt
manager software tisch am neuen kick
[Musik]
wie komme ich die elf steht in den usa
und jetzt grund mathias frank
es ist die größte spende geschichte vom
basler zoo großzügige mazzone sie
typisch und immer wichtig sie verpassen
[Musik]
und irgendwann fest aus dem großen
was ich sehr starkes instrument gesehen
es ist ein großer tag so bewegte zukunft
je mehr ich seh und verloren der stopp
es mit der künstlich natürlicher
umgebung und es ist wirklich wie verriet
der autor mit herzblut schaffen für das
meer der draht zu der tiere und der
natur mit verlierer
[Musik]